si la cascade ils pêcheront pas fait
chaud très chaud pas pêcher
moi je dis pechoux non type et chubu non
je n'ai jamais enfin le père et le père
et pauvres
riches ont pas fait chaud le fils de
souleymane verdez souleymane junior
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
frechaut papé chiberta attention bishop
avait chaud le fils de l'immense acteur
alain delon à la suite bien sûr bien sûr
voilà les
pêcheries
calme toi quand même
des choix pas pécho le fils de l'avocat
fabrice di vizio pp division
non mais n'a pas pêché au pape et chaud
le fils de notre ancien président
nicolas sarkozy de mr choisi à l'échelon
régional des pêches au gâchis mais chaud
exactement à la et là mon préféré on va
se marier aussi je crois mais on
l'embrassé beaucoup et ça pas lui c'est
un amour je suis je la donne toute la
famille était chaud ou pas p chaud alors
ça c'est le barca je vous le dis je un
fou rire toute la journée on
joue pas perso
il est le fils de péter de valérie
bénaïm kader médaille
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas qui se sont pêchés